we decided to launch a workshop here
about how to build a carbon fiber
acoustic guitar and the challenge was to
come down here in a specified period of
time and build a guitar and at the end
of it perform with that guitar in a show
generally it's a very straightforward
process and we tried to streamline it
with our workshop so that people would
get there faster so the first step in
this is basically we had to find some
sort of dimensions for the basic guitar
would be and then we put them into this
program 1 2 3 D design and we're able to
build up in the program a 3d model of
this guitar I really thought everyone
would stick with the basic design and
everyone wanted to change it so this is
a bass guitar and really the main
difference is just a little bigger body
so that's the tones a little deeper this
part on my guitar is actually wider than
the standard guitar that most people are
making my hope is to make an acoustic
bass that acts like a speaker this is a
little different than the standard mold
because it has a cutaway I decided to go
ahead and cut out the carbon in the back
and install a wood back and a couple
people are actually going to try to do a
carbon fiber front which i think is
going to be a very different sound and
we're really not sure what it's going to
sound again
the soundboard here I cut on the laser
printer and I designed everything in
Adobe Illustrator and just cut out the
lines
it was a lot easier to design than I
thought it was going to be but getting
everything fit together just right
that's with the Devils and the details
on that I've been surprised by lots of
things I didn't think you could build a
guitar in just a few weeks the carbon
fiber process is new to me and there
were just lots of intricacies in the
guitar process I've taken very precise
measurements of everything and trying to
use as much technology as I can so it's
a as precise as possible and so it's
very nice to have the resources here
because I wouldn't I wouldn't probably
venture to do this on my own